zoom
oh
if you love it
oh
foreign
foreign
foreign oh
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
oh
foreign
foreign
come on
[Music]
about every woman
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
funny
a series of terrible explosions shook
the city
the relay towers became colossal columns
of flame
falling on residents houses and
destroying the streets below
violent fires raged for several days
and when they were finally put out the
heaps of twit
little changed in the country
ministers continued to fight over power
old players were deposed by new ones
each more vain than the last
ordinary citizens remained a bargaining
chip in political games
small cogs in the soulless machine of
total survey
the ruling elite had no use for evan
after the protective dome disappeared
like father like son they shouted at him
in the mocking farewell
and only during that fall in a state of
absolute terror did
a low pulsating home drawn through the
city
filling the air
boring into every mine and
in just a few minutes the entire
population submitted to heimdall's power
from then on people thought
felt
wished and did
only what was required
is a cult of personality really such a
bad thing
after all if someone receives prey
and if citizens had previously been able
to afford to express their disapproval
of the current state of affair
but this is not the end it is only the
beginning there are still so many places
in the
replacing the wise leader is that not
the pinnacle of a ministry career
isn't that what you wanted for your son
father isn't that the greatness you
dream
evan redgrave is a god now
and what does it matter that the fate of
all gods
is loneliness
baby
a low pulsating home drone through the
city
filling the air
in just a few minutes the entire
population submitted to heimdall's power
from then on people thought
felt
wished and did
only what was required
the desire of an abstract common good
embedded into the minds of citizens had
unexpected consequences
a wave of unmotivated violence swept
through the city
people attacked one another at random
sincerely
and they did it with such fervor that
they forgot about their own basic needs
after only a month helmer was a ghost
town
anyone who understood what was happening
and who still had free will wise
sometimes in moments of weakness he
thought that punishing himself with a
monstrous sight
and saw the thought of the shredder
several floors below
seemed more and more attractive to evan
every day
money
over time the huge relay towers became a
familiar part of the urban landscape
slowly turning rusty and useless they
hung gloomily over the heads of everyone
below
and though some said that the towers
were only slumbering still waiting for
their master
no one ever found out what they were
really built for
little changed in the country
ministers continued to fight over power
old players were deposed by new ones
each more vain than the last a lack of
principles became a synonym for success
ship in political games
small cogs in the soulless machine of
total surveillance and control
evan's sacrifice wasn't in vain
none of the ministers who so
passionately wanted unlimited control
over the minds of the citizens were able
to have it
who knows how much worse things could
have been if heimdall had fallen into
the wrong hands
but in the final seconds of his life
evans still thought
could things have turned out differently
a low pulsating home drawn through the
city filling the air
boring into every mind and bending every
single person to its mechanical will
in just a few minutes the entire
population submitted to heimdall's power
from then on people thought
felt
wished and did
only what was required
heimlich deceived evan unshamedly with
the real
people dutifully lined up at the
euthanasia centers and when there was no
one left the bereans came and took
the once great country became a desert
with the frightening empty streets
evan wasn't able to see through to the
end
he was only able to marvel at how
quickly his fate had been decided and
regretted that heimnitz didn't find
enough soap for his rope
at least he wasn't around to witness one
of the largest genocides in history
and the